you
all right we're hopping in another one
we might be we might be going on a
tournament spree
first round opponent will be one of
these two it's not always the top the
top two but in this one it is mister I
am Eric Rosen let's do it
let's see if we could put in a better
showing
then the last tournament it could only
be better I think I don't want to give
up my dark square bishop to the night so
we're going to take their first
or yeah we're gonna go to g5 first okay
I'm hoping you get something on the
light squares
that could be kinda tricky to do though
for sure
Senate or not
hmm
all right let's change the structure
some
yeah
I want this move in I've pressure on the
night
go away - be very careful
my night here
- gar that h2 square
let's go here this is getting super
sharp
hmm take once
wow this is a tough one to assess must
say
I'm down I'm down a piece here
you
okay
that one's gonna hurt that was really
nice a very nice game by mr. I am Eric
Rosen hmm start launching those poems
right at me
and I was held together by a thread
pieces they didn't not like defending my
kin my h2 square in particular it's not
a not a good position to be in
restricted I'm all balled up there's
also no reason I to not have captured
the bishop there
okay hmm yeah I should have captured on
f4 and once more in this position where
my opponent is going to have a very easy
plan
let's try for this and I want to I want
to get a night on the sea for square
how can we do this I guess this is the
night is this is the night that's going
to get there fastest a little bit
careful of that square each seven
tell you what we'll take here where's my
queen gonna go I guess right here is
pretty good
my Bishop's a bit of a dummy piece I'll
go with the dark square flight square
this is a tricky one to assess I'm not
quite sure who stands better
not sure Oh maybe maybe I could have
done something on that square now we'll
try
you know I'm better have to watch out
for some fancy stuff at night move
but my queen secures my king I should be
alright
right trade
and do you have my bishop do something
okay let's get off this diagonal now
ship takes gotta take with the Queen
oh yeah that's a piece yeah a little a
little slow for sure okay they put me
they put me on the charts there where am
I at 11th page - barely
Eric Rosen berserk the second game done
fire two games in
all right
opponent let's go here secure d5 brake
pins Castle Queen c7 and then b5 not so
fast actually yeah that move eyes have
to be on the lookout for that
okay hum up upon I have the bishop pair
and maybe I force a queen trade soon put
the night in a pin see if we get that
okay yeah that's good let's try for this
to do something like that yeah so I just
want to pile
I guess c3 is necessary finish
development is all I want
ready to take twice here
let's back up
let's take now
once
I guess we'll get the flight square and
now
was it really the the smartest thing to
do just give up the dark square bishop
like that
I do have this cover though
okay up apiece Bishop c6 defend my base
points clean here
in Bishop here
and go after the king this is a cozy
shelter this is now
right well this is also a pastor we
could get rolling with this
keep going
wait didn't I just make a move there
getting a clean
okay and they're down on time whoo okay
I am in ninth
hmm
when it last time it's got 12 rosin
okay first first-place guy
let's see if we get it take them down
yeah I don't want to take like that
I'll go for this I don't mind a dark
square Bishop exchange kind of have to
be able to lay these kind of positions
that's why you're signing up for with
the caro-kann something some kind of
slow positional grind of a game
yeah I'm gonna give that pawn up let's
see if they gave me that square okay
let's take like this I still like having
this square okay I guess now we'll take
chin on the a file lien exchange ago for
this
I want this move I think I'm better
the hair as I will be able to get a
nicer King position moving in the center
let's see if this is actually true King
on e6 we both have passers King e6
all right I think their King is a bit
unions like because of this check and
then yeah I want one rock off
and I'd be giving up upon
let's get running with this guy right
now go here
check and and improve
you
I could flush the king away I'm good I'm
glad I'm up on the clock this time
around
I just want to pave the way for my king
de to move should've went here I wasted
some time there
okay had to do some time burners there
at the end that was a big win that was
that was that guy's first loss okay
well only ones who don't have a loss
first-place guy rosin wizard chess
having a good run whoever wizard chess
is wizard chess double-oh-seven
sack of sasquatch Wow I can't I can't
recall the last time we played a blitz
game that might have been some marathon
tournament three Oh
can recall a long time long time no see
all right
well I'll take the space
so none of the minor pieces are better
for any side here I don't think so I
think it's more of a structure thing I
have a little bit more space on the
queenside and that's all that's really
going on all right things are happening
though now in the center in-betweener
let's let's change the structure a
little bit I like this in figuration
uh-huh I don't want to give up the D
file this is the only open file
let's be careful okay now now I'll go
for this
and contest the and test the file I want
to go here pressure on this pawn for
starters and now I want to offset the
knight
let's improve the King once more
and now we get running with this pawn
and try and be a pest to that guy
'if I've right around the corner not not
not yet
about this
there is a night move there
about that still there okay let's let's
duck that
over here hey one trade is in there how
we doing if we trade rooks
at night is so tricky
okay we're getting forked with those two
pawns go figure
[Music]
you go that way I go this way
you
oh my god he's flying oh he got me
ah man too many too much floundering got
15 minutes left to try and do something
that was a bad game ah he's flawless -
that was his fourth win jkm Russia
we played just the other day
might have been earlier today
yeah this might have been earlier today
that we played some hyper bullet no not
quiet let's check let's check during the
game okay
I love these positions if I get an open
a file and we do have this mean takes
Bishop Queen takes b2
got to be familiar with that we're gonna
run home okay that's it that's a nice
timely move makes me wonder if I should
have played queen d8 instead of h6 so
that I can maintain that pawn with B 5
okay well but we could still play with
this structure Knight takes b5 as a
threat Queen is unprotected I don't have
to move just yet
queen is unprotected here
I still don't have to move because the
Queen is unprotected let's back up if I
go here there's rook takes pawn that's
the problem one of them one of them
all right I think I want to move my
knight soon I want to have this square
so you could transfer to the Kings side
I think I want to open it up yeah and
others now there's a little pin going on
here multiple pins skin and sharp
the bishop still app in there ooh that's
a nice move which is going to bank some
material
yeah that was a very nice sequence I got
the piece back out there on my queen
came down a boatload of material oh I
need that magic once more I may have
found it
you
oh it's being fancy there was this
ring-around-the-rosy get over here man
ah oh my god
I can't believe I lost that on time oh
[Laughter]
man I can't explain it
I can't explain it I thought I was ready
to just go into pre-move mode and those
last two seconds flew right off my clock
oh man well I deserve to lose that one
Oh doesn't make me feel any better but
yeah I deserve to lose that one being
down so much material but I fought back
I thought I didn't know I didn't
oh boy oh boy oh boy
I am down upon in this one
mm no brother I hope you guys are
enjoying yourself this is painful
mmm this is painful I must say this is
very painful what I am going through
right now
oh my goodness
hmm
I have to break at these pawns somehow
this f4 move is gonna hurt oh boy hmm
yeah just just run into that okay okay
come on Knight I need you so bad to be a
blockading machine right here you just
want to be here and camp out yes
hmm I'm going to drop that pawn I want
this guy I will be greedy now could I
not get smoked on the clock in this game
I gots what so bad that last game
Queen takes pawn is there
rook takes I think was available
okay think open that one only on the
clock 15 11 minutes to go
10 I need a four who's in first Rosen
who has slipped up only once
last game 28 26 let's go to page 2
that's where I belong in this tournament
okay just under 11 maybe we we go for
scholars mates and stuff we have to try
cheap tricks it's the only way to maybe
win a game
okay let's get on the diagonal before my
opponent Bishop a6 c4
can't take twice here as of a check
you
grab a pond and go here
now let's secure that
yeah with truck weight truck why why is
everybody going to make me on each - do
I ever do that to opponents I never do
that to anybody
everybody's trying to get me back
remember when you got me made it on h2
I'm gonna get you back and winning this
Wow
fairly quick win I got fire oh it's
gonna be extinguished very soon
can't win three in a row I did it once
oh here we go
let's see what we get
for fast player
mmm hey they're doing something a little
bit different
that's as far as I'm letting you go here
can we get some trades
I should have pinned bishop here would
have been nice
here no no why am I going there I don't
have answers to any of my questions
yep yeah I understand
I don't know Wow look at this this is
brutal man
very brutal
I have no idea what what my rook is
doing over here this is one clown of a
piece oh yeah
it's kind of like that my knight is way
out in left field
oh my rook was on her fire
have any answers oh my goodness
to do way down on time as well mm-hmm
just push
pushing maybe something interesting
happens Oh God
I should really resign yeah oh man yes
twelve eight minutes and change okay
man I needed that for somebody and as
chad has been asking how long have I
been streaming this is not even an hour
in
you
who's that somebody is saying a Yakima
key in the chat is saying this is a
terrifying position indeed very
terrifying hmm I'm falling back on a
very simple setup this is what I do when
I don't want to think
when I become way too lazy
hmm
let's open it up just a hair I'll keep
the tension try and take advantage of a
pin
these positional features
ah
maybe just double up on the deep on
yeah
watch the night away I could take there
okay and what's wrong with taking here
I'm going to get hurt
Wow
my Queens dead okay I still have some
some pieces to play with
oh look at that was I calculated look
what I found move I love it
thank goodness for a skewer that's what
I needed all along that's all I needed
to get myself back in it back in a
better mood here a skewer saves the day
I can't stop laughing I don't know what
has gotten into me I have clearly caught
the tournament bug I cannot be stopped
from laughing I could definitely be
stopped on the board no doubt okay we
got 14 5 and change look out I am
playing wild and crazy
DJ Albert I'm coming for you let's play
gambit for once right what I really hurt
you
what's a pawn to you oh you can't win
games when you're up a piece give your
opponent a pond or two when you missed
mouse clicks am I going to have
there give them up on forget the get the
e-file no budging
okay I am opposite the king
let's centralize maybe five
Wow alright b5 right now
yeah they clearly don't want to initiate
the exchange
my knight needs a new home so I need to
support I don't want to run in Reverse
we're gonna move forward if we're kicked
or even not kick we want to give this
knight a kick though get out of my house
and he's actually trapped no he's not
there's a free pawn form would have
thought am I being so generous
23 tics there's another free pond they
don't want
there's no reason let's not take that I
don't think all right let's take like
this I want a square can you spare
square mmm we'll keep this on we do
something fancy a Discovery Zone push
here setting up Discovery's fancy
getting fancy now
fancy some fancy stuff let's return
don't hurt me down on the clock yeah
everything they could start mopping up
some bombs but they have no no gas in
the tank
fortunately
down on time okay 350 it's fighting for
page one it's a it's a fight for page
one ooh jump up to eight if I get a win
here all right still fishing for a four
we got one for can I get the second the
wizard chest double oh seven why would
you stop man you are on a roll have like
five wins
mother nature called maybe
gave the wizard a ring
alright did not return Hawes mode
okay let's try for a c5
and anything now
okay majority on the queenside let's see
if I could do something with it I'll be
able to maintain this now
it's maintained got the night under
control I have b1 under control and whoo
Queen close to dead the colar gonna have
to get oh yeah the queen is dead queen
here and then that pretty quick win Wow
I'll take it
okay maybe we could go down with a win
here definitely going oh this guy he
crunched me
and that came yeah aa-men those last two
seconds
when I play this guy laughs last left
they just they're missing I know I don't
know what happened to those two seconds
okay yeah it's it's still just so
mysterious to me
Queens off I feel like I could win these
positions a lot
a real lot
control I like making position and
they're giving me a pond
I'll take the pawn
some stuff 94 then they're gonna target
the beep on my bishop still around it's
gonna box out that night okay we got a
trade in would be trading machine rooks
off and prove the king
I got a pass I was ready to drop upon
here here and then this try that ready
to push and like king Kings a fighter
where's their king going actually
goes to me
here there we go
you got a passer this guy's fast see how
fast it's going to hit hard with check
now careful
careful now
than me
where is the mate we got the mates okay
nice and easy
we got the tub you 24 with fire maybe I
get up to fourth hold my beer what a
what a great final round opponent
they're just perfect right what what a
phrase for a final game hang on how did
I say it hang on I'm Mike at 28 hold my
beer
it's my oh boy what can you do win lose
or draw this is a pretty good game I
think it's just okay yeah this one's not
going to finish for the tournament
unless uh unless what maybe there's a
serious blunder
I can't overtake that
I'll try and get in a break though get
this in let's do it right now
maybe I have this in-betweener ooh
actually the bishop is having a tough
time right check first and then take on
c5
okay could take here let's not drop the
pawn and essential eyes
okay the tournament is over these guys
going the Knights still in a pin here I
could push a key I could still keep
going here I'm gonna I'm gonna insert a
flight square first hey I have two
connected pastors and they still have
not yet address this pin these guys
continue to roll ooh it's that I was on
the roof he resigned since the
tournament is over as well over as well
okay yeah they did okay yeah a rocky
start in that one middle game portion of
the term in at least 24 total points i
finished seventh year which is an
improvement from the last tournament 113
and on first place drunk right now
second place rosen oh he had a rough
streak as well who was slapping around
drunk right now
did I play drunk right now
no last tournament I did
[Music]
third place 32 was it that was very
close for first 40 39 32
thirty-one cap how much 45% berserk ray
that was a painful us
in sack of Sasquatch
okay as usual
the 112 good games all alrighty
you